d'autres candidats briguent aussi le
poste de jean frédéric poisson c'est le
cas de laurent burson candidat du parti
libéral-démocrate ils souhaitent faire
entendre ses idées et invite les
libéraux de conviction à le soutenir
dans sa campagne le revenu universel que
l'on prône va à être en remplacement de
d'autres d'autres aides et en complément
pour certaines mais n'est pas une aide
sociale supplémentaire
j ai donné
aux français il ya forcément et cette
17è de ce revenu universel va est en
lien avec
la mise en place d'un
quand on regarde un impôt prélevé à la
source identique pour tous c'est à dire
avec le même pourcentage pour tous voilà
c'est essayer en fait c'est un projet
global